and i love the black people we need you
people i swear because no jew's gonna
make up a train
[Music]
be funny
the first black kid i ever saw it'll
definitely never play basketball
bob newhart made the claim that he was
my closest friend i have never met bob
mueller
i'll put it to you another way bob
newhart goes to many gay parties
oh julia roberts you live next to me at
the beach you know that thanks for all
the visits
anyway
i'm living about two blocks from the
broad never shows up come by and say
hello
we're closer than two blocks i have no
lines julia just not
anyway
[Music]
this man was married to a great many
women in his life they're all flat now
[Music]
but i went to the american academy of
dramatic arts which they keep it quiet
you know robert redford's jason robots
were on scholarship daughter no no no i
just walked in and started acting
ah
you don't get a scholarship you pay you
got to audition don't be a dumbbell i
hate it
read the paper know the questions
i mean what is it stop the stars
i come out and it's my trademark i tend
to maybe jump around a little bit what
do you really think about it i think
you're making a fool of yourself
don you're getting am i right are you
getting gray
yes larry i'm getting older
doing shows like this
phyllis stiller you're a dear friend
and i must tell you god bless you
god has given you the way you look
do not be ashamed of it when you were
born you probably hit the wall
i kid the black man and you know that
baby and you were beautiful to tell a
telly is a great greek and you're a
great black man and i'm a jew and i say
this for my heart on behalf of the
greeks and the jewish people don't move
into the neighborhood
look at all these beautiful people here
to pay tribute to you the senator rich
little paul lind on the end paul if you
want to order do it now the kitchen's
going to close
sorry about your seat paul why don't you
get a pillow so you can see us
[Music]
de niro is sitting there god bless you
bob he's got the beard on
to know him is a treat he's one of the
great actors of our time you ask him
uh
you asked him he'll tell you you're
chinese right chinese this girl here if
you're not get your eyes fixed
look at the chinese boat sitting there
going who's chinese who's chinese you're
in the air yes i am
ours your eyes
put a rubber band on your can and you
can take off
you're a big son of a gun all right guys
you ever think of putting a window on
your face and becoming a building
my kid sammy you're a black man i took a
guess
if you ain't black you fell into a
bucket of m m's i'll tell you that
[Music]
lovely to see you over here buddy over
here right here
you staring at them for no they that was
so sweet
to stand up i guess the underwear stuck
that's so sweet of you really when you
get older you know you get that kind of
reception you you want to walk away and
say why am i with him yeah
now i heard she gave you an ipad did you
think that was a woman's product would
you even know what it was
you know that's the truth i know nothing
about if the television goes with the
blinking at midnight i don't i don't
know the first thing about it but now i
got to know my television stays on after
midnight
how about how about
how about shut up
i bring love and i bring peace
and i've been kindness and warmth
i love the black people
the bell like people of my life
my world
they do what they're told
we're honoring mr t why
i met this man many many years ago on a
7-11 store and said give me your money
remember the words of a great negro i
say that honestly all peoples are alike
we are all working you live in my
neighborhood i live in yours right sam
right are you crazy
[Music]
chinese japanese
my ass you're a [ __ ] i'll tell you this
three years in the jungle looking for
your uncle i'll tell you this
[Applause]
no i kid you we're all brothers
god bless you my friend what is your
first name
joe
joe my ass joe
during world war ii they were all joe
you're a jew you got to be with that
knows if you're not you're an eagle i'll
tell you this
[Applause]
milton berle my idol since i'm a kid but
now milton i say this for my heart
show business in your life thyself be
thee with your new book love thee and
know thyself milton
he's old he understands
phyllis stiller gentleman who when she
was born god ran out of clay and made
her face trick-or-treat charlie
her former husband said on the wedding
night
we know each other a long time we do uh
you i know you as one of the finest uh
impressionists you do you do great
impressions
besides that i'm delighted that you have
a show because you're fresh you're funny
you're great and i want you to know
something from my heart
i never liked you
what's your first name my darling
jewel and how long you've been married
two years he's 300 pounds don't you get
worried when he makes his move
just do what you're doing now
but do you do you do a little exercise
yeah i ride a bike about recumbent bike
twice a day do you watch whatever
let me finish dave
i know it's your show but i have a
little curtis sorry a little respect i'm
much older than you i understand by the
way that snow is getting a little
brighter up there all right thank you
good luck to you i spoke to the people
in bethlehem they expect you
nice to see you jeff what do you do for
a living jeff nothing nothing
nice to see what do you do for a living
mr colas i'm an optometrist oh wonderful
i hope it goes away
maybe that would be all right for you an
optometrist
better than sitting around on the beach
all day waiting for birds to die
you're good looking at filipinos
oh god two and a half years two and a
half years looking for your uncle
navy world war ii big one big one
cebu tacloban lingarian gulf mindanao i
was there
all
i'll be with you in a minute
all trees all jungle now big cities
wonderful we went up to manila and
macarthur's still sitting am i dead
god bless you great country
i'm not going back there no no
and in fact uh in fact he gave me uh one
of those uh you know he's got a
lightning bolt is the lightning bolt
yeah what happened is this a playback
he's got a lightning what tells him
everything i say i get the feeling i got
a problem
can you hear him
the guy here in the front snap out of it
huh
an old guy right in the front what a
night
what do you talk to that russian about
you must say look at the way you dress
the tuxedos how to style class it up a
little bit he's wearing a fake dickie
when the button goes boom
mr president get some guy that's a
little help get some guy walking in
let's talk man let's talk
he's 90. let's have a meeting
that's what they do in florida the old
jewish folks hold the elevator doors
[Music]
we went uh oh many years ago my wife and
i when the trump plaza just went up and
we said we're gonna see the apartments
this is your wife barbara i'm talking to
that
no it's a hooker from detroit
what the hell's the matter with you no
i'm sorry tonight you're a nervous wreck
you're going to brooklyn like it's
exciting
build a bridge on your ass and go home
early
and uh she and i were down there and uh
we were working at the uh grand casino
in uh outside of memphis outside how far
outside what the hell are you from the
travel agency
i don't remember casino gamble who wants
to remember nobody what are you what are
you my guardian i'm not going to tell
you where i go
cheetah 40 million jews i got to meet a
truant officer here
would you rise sir would you rise
japanese no chinese chinese sure since
the water all chinese
okay stop the ban we stopped the bed the
band it's a wall
stop the band i i asked what what's the
occasion what's the occasion tell me the
occasion who are we honoring
but
forget him who else
gee it's murder i gotta come out here i
gotta try to do a job now 48 hours of
entertainers hi bob how are you i spoke
to the home you're gonna sit up friday
anyway i'll tell you this
look at the astronauts sitting over here
jeans turning winter the moon hasn't
been straight since
you got a lot of big names here tonight
some of the greats turned out for you k
medford who had a very busy schedule in
downtown hollywood looking for bad
apples
nice to see are you japanese chinese
are you
we jews we love you especially on sunday
you knock it off knock it off why i can
talk chad a very pretty girl
you can't talk to the chinese like that
with you or the money
as long as they keep doing the laundry
everything's gone
[Music]
hey hey hey like he says
for the money you're paying that's a
funny joke
man
i used to go down in the locker room you
know right the dodgers in the old day
tommy would say
oh the best one right he said go out to
the mound and take the picture out on
appreciation is true and i i put on the
uniform i said
tommy will get fine don't worry just go
out there i walk out to the mountain in
the game in the middle of the game no in
detroit
how did you get this show i don't know
we had a wonderful cruise we went to
vietnam i think i told you about they
went to china who takes a cruise to
vietnam oh look no our life is going to
be this sitting here all day long my
next guest you don't do anything for
quinella you sit in the house with your
wife maeve is calling my next guest and
she says you're home more on your home
forget about it
and george purpard who keeps calling me
on the phone saying why is that black
guy getting the bigger lines
anyway uh
george isn't jealous but when you go to
bed tonight
try to listen for a clock
your fart george is getting smaller and
smaller tell him what you told me how
you fed up with the blacks and you don't
want them in your neighborhood
but we need the blacks without them to
be no olympics
what's your name dear judy dalton judy
oh how are your
brothers the dalton gang get it dumbbell
you don't see that anymore chicken fat
on the hair with a part
i say with due respect
28 years ago we did kelly's heroes and i
haven't heard from you since
[Applause]
clint
i say it nobody else has said it and i
say it from my heart you're a lousy
actor
spielberg and all these guys at the
table
we know clint i know you clint's idea of
a good time is sitting on a pickup truck
watching his dog bark
you know what i've been doing i've been
following you on twitter you're on
twitter yeah and my wife got me on this
thing you know you write these little d
she said it gives you that that's why
she talks gives you something to do you
know
because she's in the other room going
shining jewelry all the time that's what
jews do they when they don't work they
just say
hey i'm a jew don't turn on me for sake
anybody watch your diet yeah sure i have
a steak once in a while and you know
they always say isn't that right all of
that you don't have to be that attentive
you don't have to be like
don't give me that
he gives me that crap like he's
interested
[Applause]
sugar ray is a great champion sugar we'd
ask you to talk but you know the blacks
your lips locked
so so i you're saying that's right
thomas just take the picture out take
the picture
what do you keep doing i don't know
when you make love to your lady go did
we do it yes we did did we do it
anyway what was your name again who
cares what her name is kevin bacon's
kevin bacon's wife that's right well
you're jewish that's kevin bacon what
does that got to do with why do you take
a name
it's bacon and that's the separate what
is this a nazi movie
[Music]
what's jewish got to do
heaven tonight he's black did i make a
big thing out of it
i say this
shut up i hate when i when i spade butts
in now
one more time and there'll be troops in
front of your door tomorrow
they can't do nothing because not top
dance
and josh this is great you get on top of
a farm roof and go